guess what guys it's bad I'm back it's
your boy I like I said last time I'm
quitting my job okay so I need you to
come hang out with me on my twitch
channel I'm gonna be here I'll be with
the crew with a JK but I'm also gonna be
at twitch.tv slash big boss beause you
got to subscribe you got to follow
you're gonna turn on the notifications
because I'm doing a big stream and just
come hang out cuz I'm not gonna have to
do all day all right please she needs
friends little over there please welcome
back to another episode of am I the
[ __ ]
oh yes yes where people go and read it
share some weird situation going on in
their life they want us to judge them so
we're doing exactly that you guys can
play along with us let us know in the
comments is this person now soul what
are your thoughts what are you big game
yeah we gonna read down so for this one
this is am I the [ __ ] for saying I
love you more than anything to my
daughter in front of my wife that's
interesting context matters go ahead
alright so Nikki's like ready she's like
mom ready okay so this is the husband
readiness he says my daughter is three
and sometimes gets scared I'll stop
loving her when she does something for
no good reason mind you I make sure she
always knows why I'm upset and that I
mad at her actions not her today she
bumped a glass off the table and just
started crying she asked if I still
loved her and I said I love you more
than anything and I gave her a kiss my
wife was watching and stormed off I made
sure that my daughter was fine and
cleaned up the glass and went to go see
what was going on my wife was crying and
calling me an [ __ ] who doesn't love
her why she was wigging the women is
like need him to love her so that's why
I think there's some details being left
out cuz like why do the daughter and the
wife immediately have that reaction to
him and he's like I don't know why
details me left to a kid to like like
it's like I love you more than anything
and worked
Vince that this is the reason she's
upset what if what if it's the reason
why the daughter has such like low
self-esteem please play a glass breaking
sound to me that's less aligned
she said that okay so I went in to ask
her why she was waiting yeah she said
that because I said the above phrase to
my daughter it meant that she didn't
mean as much to me is this really
something I'm not supposed to say my
mother said it to me and my dad didn't
freak out I mean I don't know cuz I want
to hear from the wife I need like to
know it because from this the way that
this guy told it he doesn't sound like
an [ __ ] cuz like telling a
three-year-old I love you more than
anything does it sound like an [ __ ]
thing to do that could be why he's so
confused right it also kind of makes me
wonder too were like his daughter is
freaking out constantly like if she does
something like what's going on there is
because it's that woman's daughter
that's what I was thinking I was
thinking the mom so crazy at the girl
like she can't yeah she leads that low
could be missing context - right like he
could come home and he's like hey honey
and then you know he picks up his his
Joe Montana football and he's like a
[ __ ] love this thing that's what I'm
saying it could be like some tension
before this incident not this incident
but like this was the last straw for her
you know because like sometimes I love
my cat so much that Steve gets jealous
and don't say this on camera you're the
best boy in the whole world and he's
like bull would about me I'm like am I
the best boy can I be the last boy
you're competing with your own guy
hey Julia why don't you say it to my
[ __ ] face I did
she's scary you tested the wrong woman
scary guys Julia down
Julia Julia punched me she'll [ __ ] do
it full force oh I would I would buy
from really bad at the same time you
would she's a big sweetie but she's I
told that I told her to punch David as
hard as she can and David accepted and
she did and then David cried it hurt him
the next day I saw a bruise on his arm
and I was like oh my gosh oh you have
done that I liked it that you did it for
you Joe but with this kills okay
monetize so Julia almost ended David's
okay so with this one like I agree that
there could be some context messing but
let's just say that there's not let's
just grown-ass woman crying over that
and but the idea that it is what it is
in the story right right I mean like you
not believe it there are some women that
are like overly but then was surprised
you know he's been with this person for
this long why would he be surprised
because it's about men are so aloof I
read something one day that this guy
posted and it was like my wife just told
me we've been in an argument for three
days I had no idea what do I do now
that's me
that is literally my boyfriend like
every day
yeah I'm jealous of those guys so and
this is why they don't even know they're
in a fight that's all the girl would be
wasting stress do it was stress so like
you I don't know I'm also like very
aloof to stuff and like I don't always
just pick up on [ __ ] like that so like I
get it but for you guys questions so
here's something I thought while we're
eating this so women tend to attach to
the husband because sometimes they take
that external validation and that
partner kind of validates them and then
when they have a kid don't like yeah I
[ __ ] love this kid but when a man has
a child they're like oh like that like
their baby girl is like everything to
them and sometimes the child almost
takes precedence over the wife because
they're like I made this how you have to
agree ahead of time we have an agreement
in place that we will always be each
other's number one ahead of any of our
children and we will always put like our
marriage first my friend to here says
[ __ ] those kids because only because
eventually they're gonna leave you and
they go do other [ __ ] and I don't even
wanna call don't return that love and I
don't even want to call my parents on
the phone y'all got that crazy look I
really do but that's what I'm saying
like for some men I mean like do you see
yourself I don't know cuz I don't have
kids you got a baby girl say you got a
baby girl that's what I heard though is
that the baby girl well it does have to
look like me but the baby girl for some
guys is becomes the world and they're
like [ __ ] the wife or whatever doesn't
matter she's the thing that I'm gonna
protect for the rest of my life and like
I love that they have for their baby
girl I just think those guys are and
there's a word that I would use
previously thirty years ago because
because it's a little it's just a little
lame man like well know all this like
daddy's girl [ __ ] let's go on
daddy/daughter dates and look like have
you guys heard of a purity ball to me
this is just short of a [ __ ] between
our Kelly they are not our Kelly who was
the gun that was looking at her Harmon
Atia Ric yes [ __ ] but this is that this
is close to that right a purity ball is
is like in some southern areas like very
religious people the dad takes the dot
like starts courting the daughter and
takes her on her first date and like
starts dating her that sounds weird why
[ __ ] weird that's why I'm saying
this all is all in that zone to me where
it's like it's a goat's my girl like
just my baby girl teach me stuff like
the guy should always walk on the
outside and he would always you know do
that by example and he would be like a
guy should open the door and like dad
wasn't obsessed I should walk walk you
up to the front door and not just drop
you off to the driveway or whatever dad
was not obsessed no he was some guys do
that [ __ ] cuz they think that's [ __ ]
yeah but you're talking about the
perverse reason for it right
no like weird like obsession thing yeah
but that's weird right I think it's just
before being that weird but there's a
whole aspect of people saying that you
should date your daughters as in take
her out on dates hang her out hang out
with the shower like what a mansion
exactly and and that is a good except a
painting is like if you if guys play the
traditional role just make money and
don't have interaction with your kids
there's no relationship and she doesn't
have a good idea of what I'm not get
that idea about how the man treats the
mom to about Howard exactly but we're
getting kind of off topic here the point
is she asked if that love can change I
don't have any personal experience so I
can't say but I have heard that right
from birth the daughter already gets
more attention because of that there's
no because because I think what it is
here's what I think it is no it's the
purity of the relationship with an
innocent being and there's baggage with
the life so that's I think what what the
my take on it oh you're right I think
yeah louis c.k talks about it in his
stand-up where he's like now like after
my kids were born i looked at my wife
and it was like you're a stranger these
are my blood dan yeah we also have a
strange relationship with women so
in general yeah well my kids report I
looked at I looked at my wife and I was
like yours changer can I jerk off in
front of you this this guy's saying that
his daughter is 3 so you know for a
while maybe the first year the wife has
really caught up in the child the second
year she starts to feel like oh my god
he loves the kid more than me and then
by third year this is the first time
he's really hearing of it so he's like
whoa I can't say that and like maybe he
is prioritizing his kid over his wife
and she feels that I think it might be
just some guys are wired that way
because I did watch this other
documentary and it was an interview with
the Iceman so this ice man he's a real
Iceman Iceman that you know real Iceman
the ice men that killed over 300 people
all right so this guy what ends up what
he was talking about they ask them is do
you love your wife and he says yes I
love my wife
do you love your kids yes right and then
they asked him like um like can you kill
your kids or can you kill your wife
they're just trying to figure out how he
thinks and he's like no for my kids I
will kill for my kids
I will kill my wife for my kids so
that's kind of like this weird primal
thing that this guy had because it
continues the bloodline it says it's his
blood like biologically yeah that would
take precedence because like this is
blood and this yeah this is not blood
those are primarily wired as hell to
like mob people yeah you guys are some
of the few people that have had the
conversation before then and I've heard
that it's healthy to have that
conversation and say the relationship
comes first always I know that one day
just like what happened to Nikki like
some guys gonna come along and take the
daughter away from the dad right or and
the mom like that's just what happens
like so there's it doesn't make sense to
me to do this [ __ ] where it's like I'm
gonna put my wife I'm gonna lower my
wife or the pedestal put my kid above
that and then wait for them to leave I
don't know if they intentionally lower
them I think it's intentionally I'm
intentionally preparing my mind for kids
like that yeah that's and I've heard
that that's the healthy way to go about
it but most people don't do that you
know they just have this now they have
this blood they're holding it and it's a
very powerful experience I think for a
man too
because men tend to be a little aloof or
not super in touch with their feelings
and when that's right there in your hand
you can't help it you feel everything I
feel like it was the opposite for my
parents
my my mom so when she had us like she
just felt this like these are my babies
and like kind of didn't pay as much of
attention to my dad and my dad was the
was always like you come first like we
were Europe here and give me attention
yeah so was having the opposite and I
feel like he was always kind of jealous
that we got more attention than him
interesting a lot of Asian families are
like that it's it's a it's a new dynamic
to the relationship when you bring kids
and then people who are fighting for the
attention yeah if one person's more into
the kids and this person's more into the
spouse then yeah there's like a
disconnect this is no different than one
person loving someone more than the
other yeah that's that's - that's saying
yeah I think a lot of like a lot of
families go back to like what Joe
mentioned before about a lot of
minorities being more about survival
rather than about like love right a lot
of like marriages so then when they have
kids it's like this is how my family is
going to survive it's going through this
bloodline you know so even like that's
deep as hell that's horniest but it
might be a little bit less horny I feel
like that's my parents because I parents
only dated for three months before they
got married that's really one like after
his dad fell sick he was like all [ __ ] I
need to produce grandkids for my dad and
so like he went out and tried to find
somebody he found my mom like that's
literally the story there so I feel like
miscommunication and disconnect
sometimes because I see the way that
they argue and I see the way they
express themselves and they do not match
at all Joe would you say that marriage
after three months is - honey I think
it's not Marnie enough three weeks it is
Oh three weeks I know someone that
married someone after two or three weeks
of meeting them and they're in their 50s
right now and they still love each other
they're still together well they're
together together in love they don't
argue so I don't know okay I like does
criteria for my own I don't know their
relationship that deep so I don't know
if maybe they don't talk to each other
all right is the most peaceful
relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]